CD lamb set two Cowboys franchise
records in the game he passed Michael
Irving for the most catches and the most
receiving yards in the season he was
selected for the drug test it doesn't
even matter we know he's clean that CD
mm lamb the best receiver in NFL not top
five not top three he's top two not two
and I think he's putting on the show and
if wasn't for that little drought period
before he had the show that he's always
open he arguably would have broke the
record I don't care what nobody say CD's
a boss he probably should be offensive
player of the year CD lamb
congratulations brother you are truly
shown why you the number one there was a
lot of naysayers I remember Richard
Sherman early in the year said he wasn't
even the top five receiver a lot of
people say he couldn't be a number one
when Amar Cooper was gone CD's still
here he just continuously to get better
and he's having a year of his life and
he's going to have a big big payday
coming soon